I think it's like the best support
system to have siblings so I would love
to have one more at least Kim Kardashian
explores surrogacy on Sundays Keeping Up
with the Kardashians after two doctors
advised against getting pregnant for a
third time
if the two doctors that I trust have
told me that it would not be safe for me
to get pregnant again I have to listen
to that but because I don't know anyone
that's been a surrogate anyone that's
used to surrogate I didn't really think
of that as an option for me Kim meet
with a mom who carried her own child
first and then have twins using a
surrogate I think my biggest fear is
just that like if I'd had a surrogate
what I just don't know like what I love
them the same that's like the main thing
that I keep on thinking about that
scares me there's not a day where I have
any thought that my love for my kids are
different that my connection to my kids
are different oh wow you know you get to
carry one and have them close to you but
the other is cuz you so desperately
wanted them in your family
Kim catches Chris up to speed on her
feelings about baby number three I've
kind of come to the conclusion in my
mind that okay I can't carry another one
and now I just want to like explore
surrogacy also the best thing is I could
have a new baby and have no one know and
live my life for a good year before we
announce it
but I don't know if it's for me yeah I
really don't know
you